so I think diversity has gotten a lot of
great you know
now empirical evidence that shows that
it generally works in groups especially
in organizations and companies that
here's the fascinating piece of it for
companies that have a diversity and
inclusion program globally only 8% of
them have expanded that beyond gender
race sexual orientation and whatever
else to include age so age is not often
thought of in the diversity realm how
it's if you want it to be I think I
absolutely want it to be and I think one
element of it is you know cognitive
diversity which sometimes can be narrow
how your how your brain works but also
cognitive diversity speaks to what your
experience in life is mm-hm and so I
actually think one of the beauties and
one of the few Europe has done a lot
more testing and and Studies on age
diversity than the US has interestingly
partly because Europe is aging faster in
places like Germany in fact actually had
to do this what they've actually been
able to show is that age diversity has a
particularly interesting phenomena
relative to race or gender diversity in
that gender diversity means a more
better collaborative skills for sure
but what age diversity offers is more
synthetic thinking more of what I talked
about earlier that ability to get the
gist of something and not to move too
quickly so what they showed in a major
German study was a young team all by
itself all by itself makes decisions
quickly and makes a lot of mistakes an
older team just older people takes a
long time and makes fewer mistakes when
you mix them together you get the best
of both worlds and that's what age
diversity can offer the the
organizational world brilliant thank you
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you